vous partez en week end monsieur mimi
voix l'enterrement et de guidon
le mien j'aurais bien peur oui toi un
trou dans la boîte à gants
antoine a besoin de nous c'est notre
pote il vient de perdre sa femme quand
même pas compliqué de passer quand il
croit la tendance pour les obsèques de
sa mère non moi je vous laisse une
claque et menuiserie
antoine tu es ce que tu vous dois faire
un petit voyage
[ __ ] mais qu'est ce qui lui prend
comme une valise est la seule tout le
monde savait déjà que ma femme couchée
la gare en serbie étaient amis me disent
que t'es parti avec une arme
sanef j'aurais préféré le tuer à coups
de pied mais avec mon arthrite
on commet pas un crime passionnel
cinquante ans après les faits pardon
mais je pars pas je sais pas vous pour
balancer des torgnoles associés paquet
avec devient aussi venu
[Musique]
c'est pas possible d'être aussi quand
c'est l'heure des comptes les rangs
servier vous disiez de madeleine
qu'est ce que vous foutez là je n'ai pas
réussi risque de nuire c'est celle où
l'on va pas passer notre temps à
regarder dans le rétroviseur on arrive
au terme du mandat on a chié trop car
notre ferme pas de remords ni de royan
cinq minutes sans vieux ce trop demander
photo g la tweet ils appâtent leicester
hameau qui renvoie pas ce qu'il a vu
dans la presse